Indischer Mann ein dominanter Vanitas whoo hey
danke Asian Lakers Essenz und Farm
Karate Yoga Gandhi Bollywood und
Informatik
meine Nautica Besetzung Abba Atkins Andre
Associazione Arundhati Roy ist - es war
mit einer ganzheitlichen Vision Indianer und
verwirklichte einen konstanten Gürtel in einem Vida Sykes
Ivica fantastischen Elan  dissed auf Vivint
@rickeon bezieht sich nicht auf CP-
Rechte für 20 gr
mit sogar verschleiertem Bestseller, der
abgelehnt wurde, weist auf Pyrimidine hin, Vitamin
, die rosa Leine - ein Schluck sicherte ein
Feuer und Sie wissen, schlagen Sie einen Drachen, ein Riese
tut ministerium das Bodensystem sieht aus
Arundhati Roy bedankt sich bewusst bei dir, ja,
indischer Besatzer, ich beende unsere
Geisterstadt einer Una, die einen Drachen aus einer Petitionskolonie bezahlt,
fast passiert, dass die Alta
gefeuert wird, oh nein, wusstest du nicht, dass ich meine, ich
denke, wir haben noch einen langen Weg vor uns
Wir könnten sagen, dass alle
Menschen in Indien unabhängig von allen Formen
des Kolonialismus sind, unsere diesen vereinigenden Drachen hatten einen
indischen HP-Schub, etwa wie Thomas in
einem Zug auf dem Meer  Tate gegen Essig
Hören Sie, es ist weit, würde nach Pakistan fragen,
wäre Trient. Wir senden uns einen
besseren Carter einmal VAR e 9, basierend auf Dine
aust
Pakistan, damit Muslime
in diesem Gericht auf indischem Marrakesch helfen, und da die meisten Pakistaner
eine Salbungsinsel ipsec essen würden
Bangladesch bis Senior von diesen sind Baumwolle,
es ist Vashaun
Gateway Minister Narendra Modis Alfred
und Aruna rosafarbene Drachen Feuerdeck
normaler Ton Umkehrung von launisch und Alfonzo
Erzähler Zaius oft Mia, die Dan Lunt
Wissenschaft im Cyberspace erobern würde Ich
Inder kann sehen, dass Hindi vom
Vatikan auf diesem Gebiet tatsächlich verklagt wurde,
verklagte ihn den Arzt Amon  Land Chardon
Valen fleischiges Lächeln und Kansas Angst
Mohan Farn Ich bin Martina Sattva, die gibt
- Panama namens Himalaya Yabba hoffe, dass
es sich öffnet und entzündete
Territorien besucht  al Spartans natürlich Pakistan
Brennan Gedichttests hier für Alaun Kaschmir
SATA Unipeg – Biden Londoner Zweigstelle Port
Huber hüpfte
Pakistan Muhammad Ali Jinnah Meister una
Pennys Chihuaha Lonnie Wasser Gita, als
Esther in Rest Indians als
Faktor für Massenexodus einen Angriff auf Austin
de Guiche Schwester
Millionen Hindus uraufführte  auf sechs Feliz in Indonesien
und Pakistan auf Jacquet McCrea zehn
Millionen muslimischen Vikas Indianer gleich war 15
Millionen Erwähnung Hanzo
Mohammed Leute für das Krebs
tun für Par Moussaka fallen in eine Million
Erwähnung Stich genießen Zwischenliga Jacinta
Spaziergang 10.000 herum verzeihen Ich berührte
Selig von  Eine Million Indianer
konvertieren ist ordentlich - Problem und Stimmung
Fauci eine hinduistische politische Potenzialgesellschaft
Erholung ja Ministerpräsident Narendra Modi ist ein
Baumschmuck
Er ist ein Mann, der
er war, bis er
2014 Premierminister wurde, war er der
Ministerpräsident von a  Staat namens Gujarat seit
mehreren Jahren im
Grunde wissen Sie, dass
Indien und Indien  Pakistan und Bangladesch wurden
geschaffen und wir sprachen über die Teilung, wir
sprechen nie über die Gewalt der
Assimilation, weil es auch
etwa 500 fürstliche Königreiche gab, die zwei
unabhängige Königreiche hatten, die
zwischen Indien und Pakistan und dem
Konflikt in einem von ihnen Kaschmir wählen mussten
hält bis heute an, und
Sie kennen auch Länder,
ich meine Staaten im Nordosten von Nagaland,
Manipur, also hat die indische Armee
keinen Tag verstrichen, an dem
die indische Armee seit 1947 nicht
innerhalb ihrer Grenzen gegen ihr eigenes
Volk eingesetzt wurde  Modi gehört zu der
heute mächtigsten Organisation
in Indien, die RSS genannt wird. Die
Rashtriya Swayamsevak Sangh ist keine
politische Partei. Die BJP, die
regierende Partei, ist der politische Flügel
dieser kulturellen Gilde namens RSS,
die in diesem Artikel war  Die Hindu-Behauptung
Carter Orgel ist auf See auf dem, was
technisch gesehen Modi ist, und mehrere seiner
Minister sind Mitglieder, ebenso wie ein früherer
Prime Mini  ster Vajpayee the RSS
wurde in den 1920er Jahren gegründet und glaubt an die
Idee einer hinduistischen Nation. Wenn Sie sagen,
Indien sei ein hinduistisches Land oder eine hinduistische
Mehrheit, ist es nicht wahr, es ist ein
Land, das aus Minderheiten besteht, von denen
Sie wissen, dass es sie gibt  Sechs
dort sind Christen, die freigelassen werden, und
natürlich die größte muslimische Bevölkerung
der Welt
, abgesehen von Indonesien vielleicht, und die
RSS wurde in den 1920er Jahren
nach dem Vorbild des europäischen Faschismus gebildet.
Viele seiner Ideologen haben offen
gesagt, dass Sie wissen, dass Muslime sind  das
Juwel Indiens und die Juden Deutschlands, und
selbst heute noch, als beispielsweise 2002, als
Modi Ministerpräsident war, ein
Massaker an Muslimen stattfand, war es nicht das erste
Massaker an Muslimen, das in Indien stattgefunden hat,
aber es war das erste in Indien  das zeitalter
der massenmedien die erste
ideologisch begründete entschuldigung für die ihr
wisst ihr wisst und oft ist der choral auch heute noch
sie singen es ist nicht nur die RSS sie
haben jede Menge zwielichtige Bürgerwehren damit sie
nicht yo können  Sie können
diese Organisation nicht rechtlich verantwortlich machen, aber sie
verbreitet diese Ideologie des Hasses und der
Gesang ist oft mu Salamanca ein Kuss auf
Cobra Star in der Nähe von Pakistan, was bedeutet, dass
nur ein Ort für die Muslime der
Friedhof von Pakistan ist, den Sie kennen und so
heute der RSS hat
Hunderttausende von Freiwilligen,
es hat Schulen, es hat
Verlagsagenturen, es hat Sozialarbeiter, es hat
, es ist an der Bekehrung beteiligt,
was sie Bekehrung zum Hinduismus nennen,
und es breitet sich heute eine
Situation aus, in der Sie
Leute kennen, die selbstbewusste Mütter sind
Moslems und Dollar zu Tode zu prügeln auf
das Gerücht hin, dass sie Rindfleisch essen oder
Kühe transportieren und man
Minderheiten ghettoisiert,
glaubt, ist eine nicht sonore Touche
Hinduistin, die ihr Fahrzeug das Bein vom
Feld verstecken, das Hinterland verstecken
, ich bin nicht hart getroffen, also bin ich  offshore meine schwester
jägerin über gut es ist eigentlich wissen
wir müssen verstehen dass es
seit den 1920er jahren kommt wie in einer
weise es unvermeidlich war  weißt du
, als Modi gewählt wurde, gab es diese
ganze Diskussion darüber, dass endlich nach Hunderten von
Jahren die hinduistische Herrschaft geschrieben wurde
und so weiter, also ist es nicht wie Trump.
Ich meine, die Leute verwechseln Modi mit Trump,
es ist nicht so, dass es so ist  eine Situation
wie Trump ist ein Ausreißer,
ja, während es hier ein System ist, das
jede Institution der Demokratie durchdrungen hat,
insbesondere die Medien, die Sie kennen, und
es gibt eine Verschmelzung zwischen einer Art
neoliberalem Unternehmenskapital und dem,
und heute ist die Situation sehr ernst,
weil die Wirtschaft einmal  Ich
habe versprochen, dass die Befreiung dieser neuen
Mittelklasse, die geschaffen wurde, all die
Aufregung der 1990er Jahre
in Panik umschlägt. Sie wissen, dass wir ein
sogenanntes arbeitsloses Wachstum haben, aber jetzt geht sogar das
Wachstum zurück, Sie haben
genug Saatprozent  gefangene
Werke nach Morenstein und alle wissen, dass der
Direkteinbruch vor kurzem richtig begonnen hat
und und dass das Wachstum auf jeden Fall mit
einem enormen Preis verbunden war, den Sie Hunderte von o hatten  Wenn
Tausende von Bauern sich umgebracht
haben, haben Sie Millionen von Menschen
, die von ihrem Land vertrieben wurden.
Wenn Sie sich eine Stadt wie Delhi ansehen, sind die
Außenbezirke von Delhi wie ein
mittelalterlicher Ort, von dem Sie wissen, dass
Fabrikarbeiter dort
buchstäblich leben  Sie sind
wie Konzentrationslager, du weißt, sie haben nicht einmal
genug Geld zum Überleben, sie leben
unter unerträglichen Umständen, ihre
Arbeitszeiten sind einfach unbegrenzt, und du
, du, du hast eine Situation, die
eine Krise ist, die gewissermaßen
von unten kommt  Sie wissen schon, und angesichts dieses
wirtschaftlichen Abschwungs und all der Wut
richtet sich nach unten auf Minderheiten,
auf Dallas, auf Menschen, die
bereits unterdrückt sind, aber die
Frustration wurde auf
diese Weise durch diese Fragen zu all diesen
Problemen in unseren herausgenommen  Sitzungen sind zu
Hause auf einem Balkon und Aufsätze, die
indischen Mystiker auf meiner Höhe verschieben, Nebel und
sahiba bombilla wie eine Spezialmaschine, um zu
sehen, dass es normal ist, das Krankenhaus zu ar  Eine
globale
Gelegenheit weiß wirklich, wo man nach Sweeney-
Szenen im Nordosten und draußen ist, um Luft zu erhitzen
und den Himmel zu verfolgen, und Hinweise will die
terranische Politik des Spions Putin
East von Aragonés von Trampas von Moody's
Bajo Cosmetics La Parisienne zu
Anfängern, um sich einzumischen, nehme ich an
hat etwas mit Globalisierung zu tun
, wissen Sie, denn wenn Sie versuchen,
eine Situation zu schaffen, in der es eine Wüste
gibt, breitet sich eine Art plastische
und homogene Kultur auf der ganzen Welt aus,
und Sie wissen, dass diese ganze Sprache der
Identität auch
wichtig ist  und nicht wichtig, Sie wissen,
wo die Menschen so gespalten sind, dass
sie nie die
Gesamtordnung dessen, was vor sich geht, in Frage stellen, aber je
tiefer die Wirtschafts- und Umweltkrise ist
, desto mehr passiert dies
zwei Kasten oder Sie
sehen manchmal einen Konflikt zwischen Hindus und
Muslimen, der Konflikt
hat nichts mit diesen Themen zu tun, aber  Nicht mit
dem Kreischen der Ressourcen, sondern mit der
Unfähigkeit, auf dem Land mit dem tauchenden Grundwasserspiegel zu leben,
und wie
beanspruchen Sie diese Ressourcen dann, indem Sie
auf Ihre Identität zurückgreifen, obwohl es in
Indien eine Gesellschaft ist, die wir natürlich
kennen  hat historisch gesehen
die grausamste soziale Hierarchie, die die
menschliche Gesellschaft hätte erfinden können, wo
ist
ihre angeblich göttlich verordnete
konsequente Leidenschaft, und
dann werden Hindus geboren, Hindus und Muslime
präsentieren und widersprechen den
Instrumenten der SSA in
Indien  sei nicht taub Kaschmir auf der anderen Seite des
Flurs, wir haben diese Gelegenheit im Film,
unsere Voreingenommenheit, schön, oh Schatz, Colin
Gunton, es ist Kampfzeit
Nennen Sie den Konflikt in
Kaschmir das unvollendete Geschäft der
Teilung, aber Sie wissen, dass ich wirklich ein
Problem mit diesem Wort Teilung habe, weil
es so ist  deutet darauf hin, dass es einmal ein Loch gab
und dieses Loch in kleinere Teile geteilt wurde.
Was war das Ganze
, wissen Sie, was war diese alte indische oder
hinduistische Zivilisation, die sich selbst ein
Land nennt? Es waren wirklich die Briten,
die sich auf einer Karte darüber lustig gemacht haben  Indien,
es war ein von den Briten geschaffenes Land,
und wie ich bereits sagte, fand schließlich eine Menge
Assimilation statt, und die
Gewalt darin, zum Beispiel, könnte man argumentieren, dass
der Konflikt in Kaschmir der
Konflikt der Assimilation und nicht der
Teilung ist, Sie wissen also, dass es ein Konflikt war
Fürstenreich war
es ein mehrheitlich muslimisches Fürstenreich und ein
hinduistischer König, der sich eigentlich erst in letzter
Minute für den Beitritt zu Indien entschied und
von dort aus begann der Vertrag erst richtig,
weil es schon
vor 1947 eine Bewegung gab, den König
von seinen Untertanen zu stürzen  so und und es wird
schließlich immer in religiöse
Begriffe gegossen, wissen Sie, aber eigentlich ist der
Konflikt in Kaschmir ein Konflikt, den
sowohl Indien als auch Pakistan gerne führen
würden  p am Leben, weil es ihre
lokale Politik stärkt, während es nicht
nur um Indien und Pakistan geht, Sie wissen,
es ist, ich glaube nicht, dass es
irgendetwas gibt, das Ihnen beweisen kann, dass die
Cosmiden Pakistan beitreten wollen, es ist, denke ich
, eine Mehrheit spricht über Azadi  Es ist ein
sehr, sehr komplizierter Konflikt, Sie kennen
jede Partei in einem ständigen Konflikt, cnz eine Illusion. Nun,
die Lösung, bevor Sie
über eine Lösung sprechen können, sollten Sie sich fragen,
ob jemand eine will, und im
Moment, im Moment, den Wunsch,
sicherlich mit dieser neuen indischen
Regierung  ist, die
Möglichkeiten jeder Art von
Konversation wegzubrennen. Sie wissen, dass es früher
die alte, wild intelligente Staatskunst gab,
wo Sie wissen, dass es Menschen gab, die
noch miteinander reden konnten, um
zumindest den Status quo aufrechtzuerhalten, aber
jetzt haben Sie eine Situation, in der  Der
Mittelweg ist niedergebrannt, also ist Kaschmir die
dichteste militärische Besetzung der
Welt, Sie haben dort ungefähr 600.000
indische Soldaten  d jetzt ist es
fast wie eine Konfrontation, wo
ursprünglich in den 90er Jahren Militante
gegen die Polizei kämpften, aber jetzt ist es eine
militante Bevölkerung, tut mir leid, die Armee, eine
militante Bevölkerung, die einem
Militär gegenübersteht, also ist es eine sehr, sehr gefährliche
Situation
Mysteriöse
Untersuchungsgedanken haben Schaden verursacht,
obwohl sie wussten, dass niemand etwas tut, was
Clique Kenzie Weaver keine Ahnung hatte
, wann dies die gezählte Seite ist, in der dieser
Manga verfallen ist.
Wir haben nicht als bekannte Krankheit gesehen
, dass viele Leute denken, dass der Titel  Der
Dienst, aber das meiste Glück ist
eine Satire, aber es ist nicht, und
dies ist nicht wirklich ein Buch, das nur
ein Katalog des Schreckens von Kriegen und
Katastrophen und Dingen ist, in denen es um Menschen geht,
sehr zerbrechliche Menschen, die tatsächlich die
Menschheit inmitten all dessen finden  diese
feine poesie, feine musik findet ihr glück an
aussergewöhnlichen und ungewöhnlichen orten findet sie, dass
es genauso viel um liebe wie
um krieg geht, es geht genauso viel um menschen  Alle,
die wissen, dass Glück keine
Institution ist, und wissen, wie man es erkennt,
wenn sie darauf stoßen, und die
Sie in den letzten 20 Jahren wirklich kennen, als Sie
durch diesen diesen
Ort gingen, an dem ich in den Herzen so
vieler lebe  Konflikte mit Leuten zu reden,
weißt du, wie ich denke mit James Baldwin,
der sagte, du weißt, warum die Leute denken,
dass man traurige Lieder traurig
und fröhliche Lieder fröhlich singen muss, und Sie werden
den urkomischsten schwarzen Humor in
Kaschmir finden, den Sie finden werden  Die lächerlichsten
Witze unter den Gorillas im Wald,
und Sie finden eine Art Widerstandsfähigkeit, die
Sie nicht in trostlosen
Häusern von politischen Analysten finden, selbst in sprudelnden,
schwindelerregenden Knöpfen, die Winterscheiße endet
- Wandern Sie auf Gewebe in der Höhe, die
Sie sein können  etwas vor, was
sie wirklich tun, denn inmitten
all des Horrors findet man Schönheit, weißt du
, und inmitten dieser Art von
Plastik-Teeny-Schönheit von
Fernsehwerbung finde ich großartiges Horror-TV
im Spa hier, dann werden wir g  et zuerst gegessen
der höchste Gelehrte oder kann danach
Marcy sein,
glaube ich, von dir kennst du das Ministerium des
größten Glücks oder den Gott der kleinen
Dinge, was das betrifft, es ist nicht so, dass du weißt, dass
es niemals ein Musikinstrument
mit einer Saite sein kann, du kennst den ganzen Punkt
Eine Geschichte erzählen zu können, bedeutet
, ein Universum zu erschaffen, um ein vielschichtiges Universum zu erschaffen,
ein Universum mit Straßen und
Straßen und Höfen und Autobahnen und
Sackgassen, und Sie laden einen Leser ein,
durchzugehen, wie Sie einen Leser einladen würden, so wie Sie es tun
würden  Lade einen Reisenden ein,
durch eine Stadt zu gehen, um sie zu verstehen, und so musst du
bei der Konstruktion eines Universums
ein Spektrum von
Gefühlen und Emotionen durchqueren, und es kann nicht
nur ein Manifest oder eine
als Roman getarnte Ideologie sein, in der du  Wenn Sie
Charaktere als Schachfiguren auf Ihrem Schachbrett verwenden
, wissen Sie, dass ich meine, dass
beide Bücher durch 20
Jahre intellektuelle und
emotionale Forschung verbunden sind, und ich fühle mich wie eine Art
Sedimentgestein, das Sie in Laie kennen  rs und
Schichten, und manchmal sage ich, das Ministerium
des größten Glücks ist nicht nur eine
Stadt, sondern eine Unterwasserstadt. Wenn
Sie es also zuerst lesen, schwimmen Sie mit dem Fisch
oben und dann allmählich mit
dem Fisch in der Mitte und
schließlich schließlich  du schwimmst mit was unbekanntem wie
die unteren fütterer unas baue einen mann
nach wirkung große meter schuss sieh wie
viele architektur studie noch nachdem
ich nicht sehen kann ich schlug auf die spule wurde
eingetaucht Mollys Schwester Kniesehne tut
Moses ist ungefähr langsam und Tish Mann kann '  Es ist nicht
einmal einfach, Architektur für
Gefallene zu bekommen, offensichtlich ist der Arm genau der Stamm
verschwommen, also war es Bianca Pete, die Spanierin,
weil es diese Art von Konzentration erfordert,
wissen Sie, und es ist nicht,
es ist kein Gebet, zumindest nicht oder
eine Bitte  oder etwas von
Gott verlangen, wissen Sie, aber ich denke, es geht um die
Qualität der Konzentration, die Sie dazu
bringen können, und deshalb
macht es mich in meinem Leben am glücklichsten,
wenn ich eine Aufgabe habe, die was
fordert all mein Können, all meine Kraft, all
meine Konzentration, sowohl physisch als auch
mental, du weißt schon, also schreibe ich mit meinen
Fingernägeln,
Haaren und meinem Gehirn und meinem Herzen und
allem und und nur das allein,
egal was irgendjemand darüber denkt oder
nicht denkt  Buchen Sie nur die
Möglichkeit, dies in Ihrem Leben zu tun,
ist ein Segen. Ich fühlte, Lisa, Sie
waren hart, keine großen Augen, das ist ein Baumeister, eine
harte Pareshan in einem Sport, in dem
Gott der Kunde ist, der ein Ozean ist
und Peeling, das in einem Flugzeug ist, gibt es
Coons und irgendein Kachelakt ist eine Sache, die Spaß macht,
aber es ist eine andere Einrichtungsfunktion
und eine gute Metapher, wenn ich versuche zu beurteilen,
dass ich ein Ökonom wäre. Ich weiß nichts
über den Wert, aber es ist  Es ist einfach so,
wie ich bin und wir sitzen und die Art, wie
ich die Dinge verstehe, die du weißt,
denke an unanständige
Zyklisierung  ist es
das d  Unterschied zwischen zwischen Sagen wir,
es ist ein Unterschied zwischen beobachten oder
tanzen und
graphische Darstellungen der Bewegungen der Tänzer aufzeichnen. Wenn
Sie nur ohne Metapher
beschreiben würden, wäre es manchmal der Knochen, es ist ein
Skelett, während die Flüssigkeit oder die
Unmittelbarkeit oder das unerklärliche 'ti von
etwas kommt  Mit einer Metapher, wenn die
Familie eine Quelle dafür ist, wenn man den
trostlosen Mahasaya Hill und die Hungersnot abzieht, war es eine
Oberflächenbehandlung Smith Mountain King, der
es heute Abend lautstark in
die Luft schaukelt, um etwas Vegetation zu bekommen,
nach der das Outside-In
nach Hause geschickt wurde  Haken Sie an, um uns zu markieren, dies
ist es edel, ehrlich eingezogen und
Soja de Mesquita aus endogenem Delhi in
der erotischsten Landung, ein neues Babylon
und Marmolada, die fabulistische, abscheuliche, siehe sogar
bestimmte Chiffre, Marmolada, die offiziell folgte,
sie beherbergt Ramsey und es ist
wichtig, dass es wieder Exklusivität oben gibt  eine
Konsistenz Antiguans Familia de famille
Englisch dann nimm es als unsere sowjetische
Sphäre Akademieklassifikation lehre ich bin
sialic push  ed unter neuen Sets und ihrer
Heimverteidigungsliga in via via abgeschnitten
Burtons Ulti auf Visia London Gazette
Sandy Claws Meter, um hingerissen zu gehen Martin
Onkel - Onkel Mitch und Sumitra Küche
die Küche
Marmelade - Mama hilft Indien weitgehend sozial auf
dies, was sie so
klassifiziert hatte CIA  Intelligence Mine
Internalisierung Ramudu ist
Tsukushi Christine so sorglos ein mutierter Indianer
der Vater und Hindus wie Bengasi Bücher
und weiter durch den Grobmotor davon ist
nur dieses innovative Acetat so
verschwommen und eine bessere Vorstellung davon, wer alle
Farben von allen und in ihrem Haus sind  Für
den Felsen tut mir leid,
Sie wissen tatsächlich, wenn Sie es sich ansehen
, wissen Sie außerhalb der, sagen wir, der
lokalen Perspektive der indischen Gemeinschaft,
was die große Sache daran sein sollte, dass meine Mutter
Christin und mein Vater Hindu ist,
und es sollte keine große Sache sein  Deal, aber es ist
wegen des Kastensystems in Indien, das Sie
wissen, weil nur 5% oder weniger Menschen
außerhalb der Kaste heiraten, weil, während
Sie es in der Notaufnahme beschrieben haben, als wir
anfingen  Wie Sie Anarchie und Gandhi und
Yoga und all das kennen, ist es wirklich das
Gegenteil von Anarchie, die Anarchie ist für
den Verkehr in der Stadt, aber tatsächlich ist es
eine Gesellschaft, die in einem eisernen Kastengitter lebt
, wissen Sie, also ja, meine Mutter ist eine
syrische Christin  mein vater war bengalischer
hindu und sie ließen sich scheiden und und und
so bin ich in diesem kleinen dorf aufgewachsen,
wo mir von klein auf klar wurde,
dass ich
nicht zu dieser gemeinschaft gehöre, die
nicht dasselbe ist wie  ein Dalit zu sein und
unterdrückt zu werden, wie wir
in Indien unterdrückt werden, was einfach
schrecklich ist, aber selbst sie haben ein
Gemeinschaftsrecht, sie gehören einander,
während ich niemandem gehörte,
ja, und du hast deine Zeit
damit verbracht, zu verstehen, warum
deshalb sollte das so sein und natürlich war
es eine Form von Widrigkeiten, die ein
Segen für einen Schriftsteller ist, den Sie kennen, weil ich
denke, dass ich Schriftsteller wurde, als ich
fünf Jahre alt war, weil Sie wissen, dass ich
versucht habe, ihn anzusehen  als  Gesellschaft, in der du
tief gelebt hast, aber du warst noch nie ein Teil
davon. Diese düstere Snob-Kunst ist eine
Angst, die man findet, wenn man von innen nach außen dampft.
Ja, das Zentrum braucht Libros
verklagen Sie jeden Karthik
Jesus, der ein kompliziertes benutzerdefiniertes
System hat, es war für den Zoo – feine
Modeflucht – Angst half, auf Tavares zu werfen,
weil diese Größe als Farben und das Ursprüngliche nicht
erhalten kann, und er freute sich über einen
Schriftsteller und Art I  kann Polizisten
sogar digital helfen, es ist das Treffen mit einem Archivar
Reinhard, der als weiblicher Mitarbeiter
mit dem Missionsbotschaftercode unter
Lloyd Beck Podium dient. Natsu, eine Bar, und
Patroclus, ein Baumeister in diesem System, ist
Hoyden, der für die Partnermauerstadt
irrelevant ist
Fragment für Entfernung können wir
sehen, also vermisst mein Schwesterteam Hoyt, um zu helfen,
tatsächlich schockierend für mich, dass
die Welt so lange braucht, um zu verstehen, aber
dieses System  tem, was wir jetzt sehen, zum
Beispiel gerade heute in den Zeitungen gab
es einen Artikel, dass mehr Menschen in
diesen Gullys sterben, die die Scheiße anderer Leute reinigen, als
die Soldaten, die in Kaschmir starben,
und Sie haben ein System, in dem Sie sogar
heute noch sagen, dass Sie es wissen
Indiens globalisiertes Land wächst, es ist eine
Supermacht, aber ich habe mir
statistisch angesehen, wie sich die Besetzung
in diesem neuen Kapitalismus auswirkt, und Sie sehen, dass
fast jedes große Unternehmen im
Besitz von Familien ist, die
Banyas genannt werden, die Handelsbesetzung, alles, was Sie
wissen und wenn  Sie sehen sich an, wer die
kommunalen
Kehrmaschinen sind, die staatlichen Kehrmaschinen, die
die Abwassersysteme reinigen, von denen einige tatsächlich manuelle Reinigung
durchführen,
was bedeutet, dass
sie Scheiße auf ihren Köpfen tragen, alle harten
Uhlets, die alle
so gegossen und der Kapitalismus zu einem
giftigen System verschmolzen sind, sind die großartigsten
superharten Widerstände  Jedes erste Jahr ist, was
der Presidente Connecticut ist, oh, und
elitär wäre kein echter Elternteil, war
Kappa-Star-Zeug, wow, Sean, sein Kondom
unterschreibt  Nun, der Präsident ist
ein zeremonielles Amt, er hat keine wirkliche
Macht, Herr.  Unkraut, ich meine, ist der Präsident
Modi überhaupt nicht,
und wir hatten in der Vergangenheit auch eine Abstimmung über einen Präsidenten,
kr Narayan, und der ganze Trick
mit dem Amt des Präsidenten ist,
immer einen Präsidenten zu haben, den Sie kennen,
wenn die Sikhs sind  massakriert, dann ist
es ein Sikh-Präsident, es ist eine
Präsidentin, es ist ein Dalek-Präsident,
das ist also das Schaufenster, um das Suchlicht darüber zu halten,
was wirklich vor sich geht, und
Feigenbaum, auch gute Neuigkeiten, oh ja, es ist,
als der junge indische Dankinger
Mahatma Gandhi, eine FEMA und eine Ocoee-Halle auf dem
Sitz baute  Verbotenes Fleisch
einbringen anständige Zollwertschätzung, aber vor der Ansicht,
aber er war jemals keine Frage. Sie wissen,
wer diese neuen Spielzeuge sind
Seine Minister sind Plattenland
, das Pub ist, und sind Angelica, die hinduistische
Kaste, entkoffeinierter Latte, östlich belästigte NZT-
Kameras, die Briten in Waukesha of In,
wie in Hunderten von Phantasien dann ein
E angekündigt  Als ich die Briten getröstet habe,
habe ich begonnen, und sie kommen auf
Elefantenohren, um den Rand des CLIA-Boykotts zu stehlen
, König Bharata Siobhan,
ooh, keine Katze dort und ihre Mission, die
Textilindustrie, Josh Horsley, seine
Spinnin in
den Höhen, sind zehnhundert Kunden, die
ich hätte Gandhi  in London einige Verfechter
Oscar baute folgte Afrikas und
politische von Pan als wenige bei der Einführung
und Ventura begann unter ihm und fließt
der Engländer adidas ahimsa wurde gebeten
entlassen Phillotsons DeBerg gehandelt
aus Delhi von Atholl-Läden hatte einen versteckten
passiven Eindringling und König und direkt und
die  Gazette Sargon erleichtert die Hansa
Africa V ein Inder Thomas M. Evita gewann
umweltfreundlich je Gandhis Zhuge of
Examiners erschreckend als Spritzer die
Ungebundenen Arbeitsmaschinen der Mehrwertsteuer von
Suhan fangen Süßigkeiten in Zenica-Lehen ein
Experiment Amitaba hatte Säure, also
Disziplin wird keinen Applaus geben und
Anführer Stanton, so glücklich, dass
Süßigkeiten welkten, als sie sich wach fühlten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
Vetrov-Vergnügen  boykottieren misspeta Liganden
und eigene Interpretationen des Instituts eines
burgunderfarbenen Panzers Honda Hassan dis van de
middle maiden und Gandhi macht bis zum
Ende jedes Geschwätz - Valda
Yancys Wunsch nach Raketen kam für Sie nicht
durch einen Drachen, der einen Tresor besitzt,
da ist unser Englisch und für Fisch das
hat benutzerdefinierte Gründe gegeben auf solchen Artikeln
her eine heilige sie fangen in der Schule
nicht an Cielo Angriff gut aussehen
es ist sehr schwierig,
in ein paar Minuten etwas zu sagen, weil das, was
Sie zu sagen haben, verantwortlich sein muss, und ich habe einen
geschrieben  Eine lange Art von Essay
darüber namens The Doctor and the Saint, in
dem es wirklich um die Debatte
zwischen Gandhi und seinem
lautstarksten Ambedkar ging, der ein Dalit war
und heute unter den Eliten verehrt wird. Wenn Sie
nach Indien gehen, werden Sie nie einen finden  Bild
von Gandhi im Haus einer armen Person
finden Sie ein Bild von Ambedkar, also werde
ich versuchen, mich so kurz wie möglich zu fassen
, aber ich möchte nicht, ich meine, ich möchte, dass die
Leute darüber lesen, wissen Sie  und
alles, was ich schreibe, ist keine
Interpretation, sondern ein Zitat aus den
gesammelten Werken von Mahatma Gandhi, also
sagen wir, ich würde sagen, es ist einer
der größten Mythen und Fälschungen,
die vorgebracht wurden, was nicht heißen soll,
dass Gandhi kein brillanter Mann war
Gandhi war ein erstaunlicher Politiker und
er hatte eine bestimmte Vision, die ich
auch heute noch respektiere, also versuche ich nicht,
ihn zu dämonisieren, aber in Bezug auf
Kaste und Rasse und in Bezug
auf Frauen war
er absolut rückständig  Sie wissen also,
was die meisten Leute natürlich aus
Richard Attenboroughs Film wissen, der
wirklich kein korrektes Bild war. Gandhi
behauptete, dass die Kaste das Genie sei
glaubte nicht, dass sie das Recht hätten
, sich selbst zu vertreten, er sagte immer, ich
werde sie in Südafrika vertreten. Der
größte Mythos über Gandhi ist, dass er
Satyagraha entwickelt hat  Kampf gegen
Rassismus in Südafrika Sein erster Sieg
in Südafrika war der Kampf für
die Eröffnung eines dritten Eingangs im Postamt von Durban
, damit Inder und Schwarze
nicht den gleichen Eingang haben
Er kämpfte konsequent für unterschiedliche
Gefängnisse für indische Gefangene, weil
sie  sollte nicht dazu gebracht werden, Gefängnisse mit Wilden zu teilen,
als er Satyagraha anfing, ging
es nicht um Rassengleichheit, sondern
darum, dass indische Händler
in Transvaal dort Handel treiben dürfen,
wo es ihnen verboten war, es ging nicht
um die vertraglich gebundene Arbeit oder ihre
Rechte und so weiter  Als er Südafrika verließ,
ging er zum ersten Mal nach England, wo
ihm der Kaiser a Hindu verliehen wurde,
die prestigeträchtigste zivile Auszeichnung, die das
britische Empire jemandem verleihen kann
Er kam nach Indien, wo
in den 1930er Jahren
die Briten natürlich nur bei der ersten Konferenz am runden Tisch auf See spielten
Unfug, die meisten Muslime gegen
Hindus zu bringen, die versuchen zu teilen und zu herrschen, wie sie
sagen, und sie verkündeten, was
als kommunaler Preis bekannt war, wo Ambedkar
der Repräsentant war, der dorthin ging, und er
kämpfte sehr, sehr, er hat
sehr detailliert darüber geschrieben, warum er
Dalits glaubte  für eine gewisse Zeit
eine eigene Wählerschaft haben sollte,
um sich als politische
Gesellschaft zu entwickeln, die für
sich selbst stimmte, damit sie
die vier
Schritte zur Gleichberechtigung kennen, die Gandhi
gegen ihn argumentierte, aber die Briten gewährten immer noch,
was Ambedkar verlangte
Gandhi kam dann zurück nach Indien und
fastete gegen fasten bis zum Tod,
gegen Ambedkar musste er zurücktreten,
und das war als Pune-Pakt bekannt,
der heute von vielen Dalits
als eines der schrecklichsten Dinge angesehen wird, die
man tun kann  Eine Gemeinschaft, die ihnen das
Recht verweigert, sich selbst zu vertreten, tun wir nicht,
und wenn Sie die
Schriften lesen, wissen Sie, dass sie sich konsequent
auf Schwarze beziehen  Der jetzt gebürtige
Südafrikaner spricht in Cafés ständig
darüber, wie Inder der oberen Kaste wirklich
Publikum sind und mit den Briten gemeinsame Sache machen sollten,
als er zurückkam und
gegenüber den Mühlenbesitzern, die
seine Freunde waren, darauf bestand, dass er die
Gewerkschaften vertreten würde, also gibt es viel zu tun  Gandhi
, der bewundert werden sollte, das Salz
Satyagraha, denke ich, eines der
brillantesten Stücke des politischen Theaters, das sich
jemand ausdenken kann, aber es gibt viel
an ihm, was
Intellektuelle, Akademiker, Filmemacher,
Politiker und die Elite gefälscht haben,
und es ist äußerst unehrlich  Sie wissen, dass
Sie heute ein System
haben, in dem Sie Studien über Identität haben können,
Sie können Studien über soziale
Hierarchien haben und Kaste einfach nicht erwähnen.
Die Linke hat die Kaste auch nie
ernst genommen, wissen Sie, also müssen wir eine
Menge berücksichtigen  Der indische Künstler Dr.
Ambedkar selbst Sie hist und nach
Hinweisen auf ein Magenproblem sogar heiß für
den Fall, dass er kein Verschwörer von
Mahatma Gandhi in diesem Fall
war, war er meiner Meinung nach einer der
brillantesten modernen Intellektuellen
Indiens, den Sie natürlich kennen  Viele
Leute sagen, Gandhi musste nach Südafrika gehen,
um Ungerechtigkeit aufzudecken. Ambedkar, als
ein Dalit in Marussia dazu gebracht wurde, auf einem
Sackleinen auf dem Boden neben
seinem Klassenzimmer zu sitzen, durfte
er kein Wasser trinken, von dem er nicht viel hatte  Seinen
Haarschnitt musste er nirgendwo anders hingehen
, um Ungerechtigkeit zu entdecken, er entdeckte
sie genau dort in dem Dorf, in dem er
studiert und aufgewachsen war, also gibt es auch
zu diesem Thema auf der ganzen Welt eine Unehrlichkeit, um
zu sehen, wie weit
er gekommen ist  von den Weinen schätzen
Entscheidung noch hunderttausend eine Sehnsucht,
wenn sie Talent in den Geist stecken, es
achtdimensionaler Kapitän entwässert unsere
Dorfteile, um zu fragen, wie Claire Hong
Kritiker ist, also das ist genau das, was Baker
eigentlich wissen Sie schließlich  Das eigentliche
Problem ist, was der Unterschied
zwischen der damaligen Apartheid in
Südafrika und der Kaste in Indien ist. Der Unterschied
besteht darin, dass das eine ein politisches System war und das
andere durch eine Religion geheiligt wurde, also
sagte Ambedkar, dass der Hinduismus für
Unberührbare eine Kammer des Schreckens ist, wissen Sie
und  Er sagte, dass wir Dalits
zum Buddhismus konvertieren sollten, und das ist
die Quelle einer großen Menge an Gewalt,
zum Beispiel gegen jeden, der heute als
hinduistische Rechte auf dem Vormarsch ist und
Indien als hinduistisches Land beansprucht, während
sie gleichzeitig Ambedkar kooptierten  weil sie
die Dalit-Abstimmung brauchen, wissen Sie, also ist es ein
System der Psychose des zerschmetterten
Denkens, aber das eigentliche Problem ist,
dass Kaste nicht nur eine soziale Praxis ist,
sondern auch als religiöse Praxis sanktioniert wird
, wissen Sie, also haben Sie Tempel,
wo Dulles es tun  Es ist
nicht erlaubt, dass Sie heute Situationen haben, in
denen ich meine, ein Bauer einer oberen Kaste,
dessen Kuh auf seinem Land stirbt, wird
diesen Caucus nicht berühren, obwohl die Kuh die
Göttin ist, und Sie werden dafür getötet  r für das
Essen von Rindfleisch, aber sobald die Kuh stirbt, müssen Sie
die Dalit anrufen, um den Caucus zu reinigen,
und ihn dann auspeitschen, wie es letztes Jahr getan wurde,
weil sie den
Kadaver einer Kuh transportieren, und wir haben heute diese
Bürgerwehren, die
Kuhschützer genannt werden und herumlaufen  Menschen lynchen und
Menschen auspeitschen und Menschen töten, weil sie
mit Rindern handeln oder Kühe transportieren
oder Fleisch essen als Familie in der
russischen Stadt, die von Russen erhöht wird,
wenn Sie das Skript für unanständigen Alarm ausgeben,
gibt es kein Licht auf dem Messer,
dies ist Kobaltpotential, das faul wird
und trete meistens mich, trete dich wegen eines
Bogens, cncd, was für eine Statistik über Stier oder
Panzer. Gut, weißt du, manchmal
denkst du, wenn eine Kultur
Gewaltlosigkeit feiert
, ist der Grund vielleicht, dass sie so gewalttätig ist, weißt du,
und es ist ein es ist ein  Ich denke,
es ist schwer zu sagen, ich meine, es
erfordert wahrscheinlich eine tiefgreifende soziale und philosophische
Untersuchung, aber heute zum Beispiel
die Gewalt gegen Frauen, die
stattfindet  Aus traditionellen und modernen
Gründen bedeutet Kaste immer,
dass Frauen und Männer der oberen Kaste sich frei fühlen,
eine Dalit-Frau abzuholen und eine
indigene Stammesfrau zu vergewaltigen und mit ihr zu tun, was sie wollen,
wenn dieses neue
Fernsehen das Internet neu ist  Wirtschaft
hat Frauen in Bewegung, junge Frauen, die
sich anders sehen, die Jobs haben,
wer das ist
, was ein kleiner Prozentsatz ist, dem zu verlieren, was sie haben,
aber eine große Anzahl, aber die moderne
Modernisierung junger Frauen ist bekanntlich auch
die Folge von Gewalt durch  Männer, die das
Gefühl haben, die Kontrolle zu verlieren, Sie haben
militärische Besetzungen, die eine
andere Art von Gewalt gegen Frauen haben,
also ist es wirklich ein Land, das
durch militärische Interventionen zusammengenagelt ist. Ich meine,
68.000 Menschen wurden in Kaschmir getötet,
aber an Orten wie Nagaland
Manipur sind es die Zahlen  könnte höher sein,
sie führen keine Körperzählungen durch, wie zu sagen, in
Amerika, wissen Sie, aber seit 47 ist die indische
Armee in Nagaland
Manipur stationiert  Mizoram Kashmir Punjab Telangana
Chattisgarh jetzt Goa Hyderabad und und
und wenn Sie sich ansehen, wer die Menschen sind
, die an diesen Orten leben, wer war die
Armee, die gegen Christen, Ardi
Wasi, Sikhs, Muslime, Stammesangehörige eingesetzt wurde, also ist
es der Kern dieses
Hindu-Staates der oberen Kaste  Weißt du, dass
alle anderen an Ort und Stelle bleiben, und wenn du dagegen argumentierst
, wie zum Beispiel mit mir, heißt das
vielleicht nicht, dass es einen Streit
gegen mich gibt, aber sie sagen, sie ist keine
Hindu, du weißt, dass alle die Journalistin
vor drei oder vier Tagen getötet wurde
Es war, weil sie sagte, dass sie
keine Hinduin sei, sie sei eine Rationalistin, die Sie kennen,
Vietnam versteckte Indianer, eine ermordete
Winterset-Sinja in Indien, die blutete
, und so kommt V in der Saison zu Indianern
, die in Indien bleiben, jetzt kommt Ökonomin und
derjenige, der eine Journalistenschicht erträgt  einen
Mordplan sehen, die Sache ist, dass
es eine Menge, ich meine, dort gibt es großartige
Dinge über Indien zu erfahren, Sie wissen, dass es dort einen
großen Widerstand
gegen all diese großartigen Auseinandersetzungen gibt  sind
Journalisten, es gibt Menschen, die dagegen
ankämpfen, und ich habe nicht das Gefühl
, dass Sie Sie kennen. Sie haben mich als das
Gewissen Indiens vorgestellt. Es gibt viele wie
mich. Sie wissen, dass ich nicht bin
Schatten von
mir selbst Oppositionsmedien investieren
leidenschaftlich distanziert ja nun, vielleicht
sollten noch mehr Stimmen gehört werden
, weil es nicht immer gut ist
, wenn nur eine Stimme gehört wird, und es ist nicht
ich will mich nicht positionieren oder so
fühlen, weißt du  weil ich eine Person bin
, die sicher mit der Stimme eines
Schriftstellers, eines Romanautors, spricht
und daher zum Guten oder zum Schlechten eine
einzigartige Stimme hat, aber eine Stimme, die
aus dem Herzen einer Menge spricht. Ich bin nicht
der einsame Schriftsteller, der sich zurückzieht.
Ich bin der Schriftsteller, der im
Herzen all dessen lebt, was Sie wissen,
und deshalb spreche ich aus Positionen
großer Solidarität, und Sie wissen also, dass
wir offensichtlich über die Dinge sprechen müssen, über die
wir gesprochen haben, aber über das, was wir tun.
t sehen ist die Pracht der
Resis  tanze die Weisheit des Widerstands,
das Verständnis von
Umweltproblemen, was dieses globale plündernde
globale Kapital der Unternehmen tut, und die
Menschen, gegen die die verletzlichsten Menschen
kämpfen und manchmal gewinnen
, weißt du, es ist ein großartiger Ort,
es ist ein Ort, den ich nicht so liebe
Land, sondern als ein Ort als Schriftsteller
, der alle Nuancen versteht und warum sich
dieses Blatt bewegt und warum dieser
Ast nicht fällt und warum das einer ist. Sie
wissen also, dass es
dumm
ist, furchtlos zu sein, taktisches Verständnis zu haben und
dennoch weiterzumachen  zu tun, was man tut, ist
wichtig, weißt du, und ich
kann wirklich nicht genug betonen, dass ich mich nicht
wie eine große Heldin fühle, die sich
für das Martyrium oder idiotischen Mut interessiert.
Ich genieße das Leben und ich schreibe gerne
und ich denke, es ist wichtig, alles zu tun,
was du tust  um zu überleben,
taktisch zu sein und weiter zu streiten und spaß zu
haben und die widerstände zu ärgern wir
leben straßenstadt heimatgebunden sein
das darfst du nicht zulassen - peti  Grund dafür,
nachdem ich und Sie nicht einmal sehen, für die
Arbeit wirklich sehen, ominös gut es ist nicht,
es funktioniert in beide Richtungen, es schneidet in beide Richtungen, Sie
wissen, es ist auch, es zieht auch an, Sie
wissen, ich meine, jeder weiß, dass auf jeden
Fall ein Verfahren gegen mich eingereicht wurde  Jeder Angriff auf mich
ist wie eine Bewerbung bei der
Regierung. Weißt du, wir haben
ihr das angetan, also weißt du, zum Beispiel meine letzte
Buchvorstellung, nicht diese, aber als ein Buch mit
Essays herauskam, kam eine Gruppe von
Leuten und zertrümmerte die Bühne  und so weiter,
und sie sind jetzt die Hauptsprecher der Regierung
in Delhi, also wissen Sie, es
ist auch so, dass alles
, was Sie wissen, mit mir zu tun hat, funktioniert wie eine
Bewerbung,
es zieht die Aufmerksamkeit von Leuten auf sich, die Sie am
liebsten schließen würden, Sie kennen einen
Kapuzenpulli meine Indianer Dachboden wer ist der
Demokrat entweder Allianz Kommandant hallo
Million erwähnt die CIA also war es hinterher
für seinen Anfang der Dunkelheit und des Nebels
dieser Seitenteil Indianer explodieren doch ja
es ist wie eine Demokratie für manche
Leute, du kennst es  ist eine Demokratie für
die Elite, und dann ist die Bedeutung der
Demokratie auf Wahlen geschrumpft,
und Menschen nehmen an Wahlen
zu Millionen teil, weil sie wissen müssen,
dass es nicht alles ist, was
sie jetzt haben, selbst wenn die Wahl
zwischen
Menschen besteht, die  scheint keine Wahl zu sein, Sie
wissen, die Kongresspartei, die
natürlich Gandhi gehörte, um Indien zu regieren,
ja,
die mächtige, launische, aber sie bereitete den
Boden, weil sie auf ihre eigene Weise
absolut elitär, absolut kommunal,
absolut kommunal, absolut, obere Kaste, Osten, Sie
wissen, dass sie sie vorbereitet hat  Der Boden für den
Horror, den wir jetzt sehen,
bereiteten viele Liberale den Boden dafür,
wissen Sie, als einige von uns
vor vielen Jahren die Warnglocken läuteten
, sagten sie, oh, sie sind extrem
oder sie sind links oder sie sind
Alarmisten  oder sie sind übertrieben, aber jetzt
sehen Sie, worum es ging. Ich meine,
seit den Atomtests im Jahr 1999 hat
der öffentliche Diskurs Dinge völlig verändert
, die Sie nicht sehen konnten  In der Öffentlichkeit
fingen Sie an, sagen zu können, dass Hominis
explizites Zeichen für Indien auf der ganzen Welt sieht.
Ich sehe, dass Häuser und Kapital am
kritischsten interessiert sind, weil unsere
Zirkuskünstler UKW-Sperren einstellen, die gegenüber
wichtig sind. Sie wissen, wer an sie geglaubt hat
Alle bemerkten, dass
wir alle Scans bei uns durchgeführt hatten, die
gut waren. Zunächst einmal wissen Sie, dass ich
meine, als ich anfing, darüber zu streiten, Sie
wissen, dass es wirklich um die Probleme ging, die
Sie in einem Land wie Indien sehen, wenn
grundlegende Infrastruktur privatisiert wird
, wissen Sie und jetzt  die Privatisierung des
Bildungswesens die Privatisierung des Gesundheitswesens
die Privatisierung der Elektrizität Sie
sahen einen enormen Sie sahen natürlich den
Aufstieg einer Sie sahen zumindest den Aufstieg einer
Mittelklasse, was für Europa und den
Westen äußerst aufregend war, selbst in
Indien war es aufregend, weil
Sie hatten Millionen von Menschen, die
plötzlich Teil eines Verbrauchermarktes wurden, was
Sie tun, was Sie nicht gesehen haben, waren die
Millionen von anderen, die
hineingedrängt wurden  Um Elend zu vernichten, wissen Sie,
also müssen sie einige Mindestsicherungen sein
, Sie wissen, was Sie
jetzt sehen, ist eine Kultur, in der die
Armen, die früher einen Platz in der
Kunst hatten, wissen Sie, im Kino, das war
uns immer bewusst  die Tatsache, dass
wir ein armes Land waren, weißt du, aber jetzt ist der
Pool verschwunden, es gibt keinen
Platz für sie in den Dörfern, es gibt
keinen Platz für sie, in den Städten, es gibt
keinen Platz für sie in der Vorstellung, also
hast du zum Beispiel einen Bürgerkrieg, der
Niemand spricht jemals im Herzen
Indiens, im bewaldeten Herzen Indiens,
wo Millionen von
Ureinwohnern von ihrem Land vertrieben werden, weil dieses
Land an
private Infrastrukturunternehmen übereignet wurde.
Wie gehen Sie also vor? Sie überschwemmen den
Wald mit Paramilitärs  Du gehst und brennst
Dörfer nieder, vergewaltigst und tötest Frauen, du
erschaffst Bürgerwehr-Stammesarmeen, die es
dann so aussehen lassen, als wäre es ein Bürgerkrieg
zwischen diesen Stämmen, also wie kannst du es nicht
kritisieren, weißt du?  wenn du zehn
Leute in einem Raum hast und vier von ihnen oder
drei von ihnen sehr wohlhabend sind und
eine wirklich gute Zeit haben
und ein eigenes kleines Universum geschaffen haben
und der Rest der sieben in
großen Schwierigkeiten steckt und du '  Wenn wir über
diese sieben sprechen und die Leute sagen, aber warum
redest du nicht über das Positive, du weißt,
es ist es ist es ist es nicht
und und und was am gefährlichsten
ist, ist, wie nachhaltig es ist, weißt du,
wenn ich über Kaste und spreche  Kapitalismus
Sie sehen, wie ich sagte, die Unternehmen
werden von dieser Handelskaste geführt,
also ist Indien kein Land, dessen Wirtschaft
gewachsen ist, weil wie in China ein
Großteil davon
aufgrund des Bergbaus hergestellt wird oder es einfach
verkaufen kann, was Sie nicht tun
Du kennst den Traum eines jeden Geschäftsmannes kaufen zu müssen, und so
erschaffst du eine Situation, in der
der Grundwasserspiegel absinkt, die
Flüsse austrocknen und du eine Bevölkerung hast
, die auf dem Land lebt, von dem du weißt, dass es das nicht ist,
und so hast du eine landwirtschaftliche Krise
so so, in vielerlei Hinsicht schwanken die
Dinge, weißt du, aber es
ist auch, wie ich schon sagte, ein Land mit einer
bemerkenswert bemerkenswerten Bandbreite an
Verstand und Weisheit, es ist ein Land, in dem die
Menschen immer noch nicht alle
homogenisiert sind
und es immer noch nicht sind  Ich habe die gleichen
Konsumträume wie alle
anderen, also weißt du, dass es eine Qual ist, die ich
sogar für Politik sehen kann. Häuser für sogar
die höchsten Künstler
mich sehr interessiert
etwas Zahnseide
diese in der Tat Stadt zu ins er hat Landis
gut Ich bin sehr besorgt Ich bin sehr sehr
besorgt für besonders über die nächsten zwei
Jahre, denn wie gesagt, Sie wissen,
dass die neue Mittelklasse
in einem Flugzeug saß  Ich warte
voller Aufregung darauf abzuheben, dass das Flugzeug
in der Luft eingefroren ist und die Aufregung und
Heiterkeit sich in Panik und Wut verwandelt hat,
dass die Wut gestorben ist, Sie wissen schon, sie
richtet sich jetzt irgendwie gegen Sie wissen, Muslime
oder Verspätungen o  r säkular oder marxistisch oder
was auch immer es ist, aber irgendwann
mussten wir zwei Jahre bis zu den
Aktionen und mit Ihnen wissen Sie, ich weiß nicht,
ob Sie von der Monetarisierung gehört haben,
wo Sie letztes Jahr plötzlich wissen, dass 80%
der Währung für illegal erklärt wurden  Das
hat dazu geführt, dass die Zahlen
gerade zu einem regelrechten Rückgang der Arbeitsplätze und
der Wachstumsrate selbst geführt haben. Der einzige
Weg, wie diese Dispensation
bei den nächsten Wahlen an der Macht bleiben kann, besteht darin, Streit zu schaffen,
um die Menschen zu polarisieren, um
die Feuer entweder wieder zu entfachen  Krieg oder kommunaler
Konflikt, und Sie können bereits die
bedrohliche Atmosphäre sehen, die sich aufbaut.
Sie wissen, dass ich sehr, sehr, sehr besorgt
darüber bin, weil die
Opposition dezimiert wurde, also wissen Sie, dass es wirklich
das erste Mal ist, dass wir mit Sicherung
eintreten  eine Zeit, die wir nicht vollständig
verstehen und in der wir noch nicht waren, bevor
Horford Ostelhoff Mr.  tapfer,
was ist all diese Emissionsintensität
auf indisch, um entweder Hymnen oder ein Missbrauchsrecht zu servieren,
und sie sagen, dass sie
Hundefutter fordern
, dass Sie gehen, danke, danke, als
nächstes, frisch, was mein Kollege,
jüdisches Abendessen, Stefan Asia,
Journalist, Garage, sie trifft  Gefunden, dass
ich das Salton Sea erreichen werde, habe ich einen
freundlichen Sturz einer Person, die 450 g auf
Rechnung eine Mahlzeit besaß, als ich im
Herbst als Kunde zurückkehrte, und ein hageres Gespräch mit Blake Monty
kämpfte
auch klettert es auf versicherung auf tack
[musik]
du